good evening i'm uprightly graham I'm
the co-owner politics and prose along
with my wife was in Muscatine Oh behalf
with the entire staff welcome a few
quick administrative notes please turn
off your cell phones a few if you
haven't already when we get to the Q&A
part of the session because c-span book
TV is here filming and we're filming
also for our own YouTube channel no we'd
appreciate it if if you have a question
if you'd find your way to that
microphone there so that not only
everybody watching on the film could
could hear you and everybody in the
store but Jean who's 83 would very much
appreciate being able to hear you so
please be considerate of him and
everybody else if you have a question
and finally at the end before you come
up to get your books signed our staff
our staff would ask that you fold up the
chairs that you're seated in and lean
them against them against something that
looks like it won't won't topple over so
this must be a crowd of truly hardcore
presidential history enthusiasts either
that or at least some of you are just
looking for a distraction from the
presidential history happening before us
on a daily basis in any case it's really
a pleasure to introduce a Jean Edward
Smith and who has of course proven
himself to be a very distinguished
biographer of presidents and other
notable American figures he's written
about Eisenhower FDR and grant
he's also profiling the lives of John
Marshall and Lucius play all this while
holding down a day job and as a
professor several universities he was
longest with the University of Toronto
for 35 years and and then a dozen years
at Marshall University
he's also been
at Princeton and Columbia and University
of Virginia and several other schools
which I'm probably leaving out now he's
zeroed in on the presidency of George W
Bush that gene is very critical of our
43rd president and no question whether
it's the misguided invasion of Iraq and
the embrace of torture tactics the
fumbled response to Katrina there's much
to be critical about and Jean places
responsibility for the administration's
resonating failures firmly on the former
president notwithstanding the influence
that also was wielded by such major
figures as as Cheney and Rumsfeld but as
a review in The New Yorker said Gene's
book quote doesn't feel like a hatchet
job it's in the words it's in the words
of the of the New York Times quote a
comprehensive and compelling narrative
in USA USA Today said gene quote writes
with a deft sweet and sense of history
speaking of how gene writes one of the
most interesting tidbits that I learned
about him from the acknowledgments in
Bush the book is that he still composes
in longhand on yellow legal pads he then
has someone type up what he's written
and when you consider that this book
totals 800 pages in print that's a lot
of legal pads please join me in
welcoming Jean David snow
thank you very much this is my
introduction of a third biography here
in politics and prose earlier I did FDR
and hides an hour and it's always a
pleasure for me to return to Washington
where I was born 83 years ago and went
to elementary school interior high
school in high school I was not
permitted to interview George Bush for
the biography Dick Cheney whom I
interviewed a number of times set up an
interview for me with the with the
president at the butch Library in Dallas
and just before I was to fly out I got a
call from one of Bush's aides who said
the president doesn't want to see you
have you had written a book you've
written a book critical of his father
and for that reason he does not wish to
see you which was true in 1992 I wrote
George Bush's war dealing with the first
Iraq war and it was critical of the
Bush's decision in Iraq and before I
begin let me make two remarks so that to
put the brief biography in context first
when it came to national security policy
George W Bush was absolutely in charge
all the decisions were his he was indeed
the decider as he called himself
after 9/11 he relished his role as
commander in chief and everything became
chain of command Bush was not a tool of
Cheney or Condoleezza Rice for the
neo-cons or anyone else he was the
driving force whether it was CIA
renditions or NSA snooping or the war in
Iraq these were all personal decisions
made by the president and everyone in
the administration fell on the line in
that context let me say a word about the
National Security Council the NSC was
established by the Republican 80th
Congress in 1947 and the idea behind it
was to prevent the concentration of
power in the White House that had
happened under FDR in World War two
was modeled after the British War
Cabinet and was designed to bring the
Secretary of State in the Secretary of
Defense military leadership in the
conference with the President on
national security issues
Truman used the NSC that way Eisenhower
used the NSC that way Eisenhower met
with the NSC every week one Thursday at
10 o'clock and in his eight years in the
White House he presided over 314
meetings of the NSC the change came with
John Kennedy Kennedy appointed McGeorge
Bundy as his national security adviser
neither Truman nor Eisenhower had a
national security adviser and the size
of the staff mushroomed under Truman and
Eisenhower the staff of the NSC were
basically note-takers and a minute
keepers and numbered about three or four
under Kennedy the size of the staff
increased to 20 and began to handle
policy issues it doubled again when
Kissinger became the national security
adviser to Nixon and by the time George
Bush took office numbered well over a
hundred
these were professional experts in
specific areas in many respects the
National Security Act of 1947 had been
turned on its head instead of a body
that coordinated government policy as
was intended the National Security
Council staff became a policymaking tool
to the President Bush ran policy from
the White House and the national
security staff allowed him to do so the
second point I would like to make is
that Bush is a born-again Christian who
saw the world in biblical terms that was
especially true after 9/11 which defined
the Battle of terror against terrorism
as a struggle between good and evil he
saw himself as God's agent placed on
earth to defeat the forces of Satan
that religious fixation is the common
denominator behind both the domestic
excesses of the Bush administration and
his it the foreign policy decisions that
he made you know in many respects to
contrast Abraham Lincoln his interesting
Lincoln in 1861 after the Battle of Bull
Run was visited by a delegation of
Protestant ministers and the spokesman
for the group told Lincoln that he had a
vision from heaven the night before and
looked and the president had said that
he was on Lincoln's side Lincoln replied
I hope the Lord is on my side or what I
really need is Kentucky today is George
Bush's 70th birthday he was born in New
Haven Connecticut on July 6th 1846 and
upon his father's graduation from Yale
the family moved to Texas where the
senior Bush went into the oil business
George W grew up in Midland when it came
time for high school he went to Andover
where he finished near the bottom of his
class the Dean of Students at Andover
told George not to bother to apply to
Yale because his grades were so low he
could not possibly get in but George did
so and was admitted George was a fourth
generation legacy at Yale his
grandfather his father
his great-grandfather all had gone to
Yale and at the time George applied Yale
was admitting 52% 52% of the legacy
applicants Princeton and Harvard were
admitting 14% Kingman Brewster became
president of Yale during George freshman
year and changed the rules
from that point on Yale would only would
would take the same amount of students
at Princeton and Harvard took 14% Bush's
three brothers and his sister had the
same legacy credentials that he did none
of them got in because Bruce retains
rules which did no better at Yale then
he did it Andover returned to Texas and
spent the next five years in the
wilderness
his father arranged for him to be
commissioned in the Texas Air National
Guard which deferred him from service in
Vietnam and his career in the Guard has
become a matter of controversy it was
during these five years that Bush drank
heavily and used drugs he was admitted
to the Harvard Business School in
September of 1973 and it's one of the
few graduates of Harvard Business School
if not the only one not to have a job
offer when he graduated
Bush had 53 interviews with fortune 500
companies and did not receive a job
offer one of his classmates at the
Harvard Business School told me his
classmates considered him dynamically
ignorant with no job offer which
returned to Texas and like his father
went into the oil business buying leases
on property hoping to strike oil to 1977
he married Laura Welsh the following
year ran as the Democrat as the
Republican nominee to succeed retiring
Democratic congressman George Mahon it
does of you her as old as I will
remember that Mahon was chairman of the
Appropriations Committee for for 12
years and was a senior member of the
House Bush lost the election returned to
the oil business prospered for several
years through family connections but the
downturn and oil prices hit hard which
profited from several futurus mergers
and eventually sold out it was during
this time that Bush became a born-again
Christian in his memoirs Bush credits
Billy Graham with his rediscovery of God
but the fact is the conversion came a
year earlier by a lesser-known
evangelist named Arthur Blissett was
also true at this time that at this time
that Bush gave up drinking the occasion
was his 40th birthday celebration
at the Broadmoor Hotel in Colorado
Springs Bush became who's celebrating
his 40th birthday which became
hopelessly intoxicated work up woke up
the next morning with an incredible
hangover and resolved to quit great
drinking Laura said it was because he
got the bill for the previous night's
celebration actually it was because
George recognized that his father was
running for president and he didn't want
to embarrass him in any way so he
stopped drinking it was 1986 and no
longer in the oil business George and
his family moved to Washington to his
assistant his father's presidential
campaign in the ABA election George was
given an office campaign headquarters in
the Woodward building which is down on
15th Street near the White House his
office was between Lee Atwater who was
managing the campaign and Roger Ailes
who was handling the publicity now head
of Fox News and for the next two years
George learned about electoral politics
from two gifted practitioners poppy ran
against George Michael Dukakis and
George Curley saw at firsthand how to
run a presidential campaign when the
election was over in November of 88
George declined an appointment to work
in what his father's administration and
returned to Texas he started an informal
campaign to run for governor
but at the same time helped organized a
syndicate to buy the Texas Rangers
baseball team the Rangers you may recall
or the old Washington Park the the
Washington Senators expansion team an
expansion team that had been formed here
in 1961 moved to Texas in 1972 though
they were scarcely pennant contenders
the deal to buy the team came through
wish step back from running for governor
and for the next four years was the
public head of the Texas Rangers he
owned only two percent of the stock
built a new stadium had really basked in
the glow of an improving baseball
franchise Bush assisted in his father's
election in 1992 and but from a distance
he stayed in Texas and when Clinton won
the election set his sights on running
for governor of Texas jeb at the same
time decided to run for governor of
Florida Bush was running against
incumbent and Richardson Texas Richards
was heavily favored in Florida Jeb was
favored to defeat the Democratic
incumbent Lawton childs but the election
was an upset George won in Texas
Jeb lost in Florida and from that point
on George became the likely successor to
his father Texas is really the largest
the second largest state in the Union in
terms of area and the second largest in
terms of population but the governor of
Texas has no executive authority that
reflects the post-reconstruction
Constitution 1876 which stripped power
from the governor the governor of Texas
is essentially a symbolic figure a
little like the Queen of England most
most most political science scholars of
state government consider the Texas
governorship the weakest in the United
States the governor of Texas cannot even
issue pardons for cannot even issue
pardons in that setting bush thrived
as a symbolic leader of Texas he was
overwhelmingly reelected in 1998 and he
also built a very effective political
machine they're led by Karl Rove and
Karen Hughes and was quite quietly
exploring the possibilities of running
for president in 2000 which announced
his candidacy on June in June of 1999
defeated John McCain in the primaries
was nominated almost unanimously at the
Republican convention Al Gore was the
Democratic nominee and was heavily
favored to win the election Gore fumble
almost immediately when he chose joseph
Lieberman who was the most conservative
Democrat in the Senate as his running
mate ostentatiously snubbed Bill Clinton
throughout the entire campaign and did
poorly in the three television debates
with Bush the choice of Lieberman and
the snubbing of Clinton gave third party
candidate Ralph Nader and opening on the
left he would ultimately Nader would
ultimately poll about three million
votes and the election came down the
floor Gore failed to carry ten states
that Clinton had carried in the 1996
election any one of which would have put
him over the top the Supreme Court as
you know ultimately decided the election
Bush became president
and Bush was superb as a politician
seeking votes but he had no executive
experience little knowledge of
International Affairs had really not
traveled abroad a short extensions a
short attention span and genuinely
believe that he was God's agent put here
on earth with the exception of
appointing : Powell as Secretary of
State
Don Rumsfeld as Secretary of Defense and
his friend Don Evans as Secretary of
Commerce he delegated the selection of
his cabinet another top federal
officials to Dick Cheney and closeted
himself in the White House with his
staff from Texas plus Condoleezza Rice
as this National Security Advisor and
Andy card as chief of staff now if you
think about it it's inconceivable that
Franklin Roosevelt would have turned the
selection of his cabinet over to John
Garner
or that or that Dwight Eisenhower would
have allowed Nixon to do that especially
after the scandal as a result of
Cheney's input Bush took office with a
phalanx of sub cabinet appointees were
powerfully motivated and already
equipped to provide the intellectual
justification for the president's
policies conservative and outlook and
articulate these like-minded ideologues
and longtime friends scooter libby paul
wolfowitz oleate Abrams Cheney played an
important role during Bush's first two
years he had an office in the White
House his staff became part of the White
House staff they were all White House
staff the administration's position on
energy the revision of the tax code in
2001 and after 9/11 the presidential
directive to try al Qaeda members by
military commissions all reflected
trainees input but over the years its
influence faded
initially Bush devoted himself to
domestic issues the United States had
run a budgetary surplus under Clinton
for the last three and a half years
Clinton had applied the surplus reducing
the national debt Bush insisted that the
surplus money should be returned to the
taxpayers it's your money he said
frequently on the election trail and it
is urging Congress election one of the
largest tax cuts in American history he
also pressed education reform that first
year in this case No Child Left Behind
which congress also enacted Bush rarely
touched foreign policy issues in his
first month in office but when he did so
it was with any determination to assert
American supremacy the Clinton
administration and South Korea had
worked since 1994 to bring North Korea
back into the family of Nations the
United States and South Korea would
provide economic assistance for North
Korea in return for which North Korea
would abandon its nuclear program
Madeleine Albright visited Pyongyang in
December of 2000
South Korea President Kim dae-jung came
to Washington in March of 2001 really to
put the final seal on the deal with
North Korea North Korea was on the verge
of renouncing nuclear weapons and
signing a peace treaty with the south
Bush rejected the idea now this wasn't
something that bubbled up from anyone in
the White House staff the North Koreans
are evil he believed and the government
must be replaced this was Bush's
personal decision the attacks of 9/11
were surprised but merely reinforced
swishes view of good versus evil
in many respects the attacks of 9/11
have been a defining moment in American
history by conflating the attacks with
Saddam Hussein Bush led the United
States into a three trillion dollar war
in Iraq promulgated a doctrine of a
preventive war alienated most of
American allies weakened its alliances
and inspired young Muslims throughout
the world to join the jihad domestically
the hysteria released unleashed by the
Bush administration undermines civil
liberty eroded the rule of law and
tarnished the respect and traditional
American values of tolerance and
moderation
I am the war President Bush once boasted
and on September 12th he assumed total
responsibility and total authority as
the nation's commander-in-chief that
morning Cheney offered to lead a group
of cabinet officers to devise policy
Bush rejected the offer this is a job
for the commander-in-chief and cannot be
delegated said Bush rather than treat
the events of 9/11 as isolated incidents
rather than handle them through the
political process Bush depicted them as
acts of war by the forces of evil I
won't really tonight go into Bush's
assault while American civil liberties
in the book I devote two chapters to NSA
spying and the torture trail and the
record is clear Bush genuinely believed
that he was fighting the forces of Satan
and as a result if you're doing that no
holes are barbed whether it is enhanced
interrogation techniques the
extraordinary rendition or the intercept
of private communications here in the
United States
Bush thought he was God's agent in the
final fight to rid the world of evil
let me say a few words about the war in
Iraq from the beginning Bush was
determined to remove Saddam Hussein the
intervention in Afghanistan was simply a
warm-up Bush instruct instructed the
Department of Defense to prepare to
invade Iraq and Anora ignored the
findings of view and weapons inspectors
Hans Blix and all Hamad Elco Bharati
that Saddam had no weapons of mass
destruction planning for the invasion
began early in 2002 and the military
assumed that the purpose was to remove
Saddam Hussein destroy whatever weapons
of mass of mass destruction might be
found and leave Iraq as soon as possible
Rumsfeld and secretary Rumsfeld and
general franks believe 90 days should be
sufficient and that's what the military
plan for the invasion took place the
dominant was toppled the search for
military weapons began and the military
began to withdraw leaving it to the
Iraqis to work things out as both the
State Department and the Defense
Department saw it Iraq had been
liberated and it was up to the up to the
Iraqis to move ahead on their own the
baddest party remained in control the
army the Iraqi army remained in place
under American tutelage and the senior
leadership of a senior leadership
Council established by General J garner
with developing plans for a new
government and Iraq most importantly was
still a secular state but on May 1st
2003 speaking on the flight deck of the
Abraham Lincoln Lincoln under a banner
that read mission accomplished
Bush said that the purpose was of the
invasion was to bring democracy to Iraq
that the United States forces would
remain there until that was accomplished
Bush changed the mission without
consulting anyone the decision was
unilateral instead of liberators the
army would now become occupiers and
would bring democracy to Iraq
Rumsfeld Franks Powell were all
dumbfounded by this change but
acquiesced and in retrospect they
probably should have done so let me
digress just for a moment to explain the
difference between being liberators and
being occupiers liberators set a country
free occupiers impose their will in
World War two as d-day approached
Franklin Roosevelt didn't want to be
bothered
governing occupied France and so instead
over Roosevelt's vigorous objections he
brought the Gaul from North Africa and
six days after d-day de Gaulle landed
and the Free French took over the
government of liberated France the
United States and British and Canadian
troops moved ahead without regard for
what was happening in France that was
the Gauls responsibility but when they
crossed into Germany Germany became
occupied the whole government was
disbanded and the Allies took control
France was liberated Germany was
occupied it's really a very important
distinction as for a wreck the Defense
Department the State Department and all
the military assumed that they were
liberating Iraq from Saddam and that the
Iraqis had worked things out for
themselves then on May 1st on the flight
deck of the Abraham Lincoln Bush
unilaterally changed direction instead
of liberators coalition forces would
become occupiers and really it was
downhill from there Paul Bremer was
appointed to head the up there to head
the occupation as the president's
representative the baddest party was
outlawed the Iraqi army was disbanded
most government offices were closed
Brenner
Bremer reported directly to the White
House not to the Defense Department or
the State Department coalition forces in
many respects became the enemy Bush
bears sole responsibility to that
decision
and if I might let me just say a word or
two about the situation at the Abu
Ghraib prison we've all saw the the the
the photos of the atrocities that were
committed at Abu Ghraib what we what we
did not know at the time and maybe and
what we did not know at the time was
that was it the the military police on
on duty as guards in the prison we're
not acting on their own there they
weren't simply Hillbillies from
Cumberland Maryland they had been urged
by the CIA and military intelligence to
abuse the prisoners before they were
being integra gated to set them up to
set them up to confess in the
interrogation that would follow for
subsequent military investigations the
first by major-general Antonio to Guba
have documented clearly that the
outrages we saw were a deliberate effort
to break the will of the prisoners
before they were integra gated by 2006
Bush became deeply distressed that about
the situation in Iraq he authorized the
surge number of US troops to regain the
initiative and found General Petraeus to
command Petraeus is an interesting
figure the army passed him over for
promotion from major-general to
lieutenant general in 2003 among other
things because they thought he was too
ambitious he was promoted to three-star
rank by Rumsfeld's recommendation to
George W Bush who promoted him and his
career took off you know and he was
indeed ambitious I shouldn't say this
with so many of my classmates here but
when he was head of the CIA a group of
Princeton alumni wanted him he wanted
him to become president of Princeton
and then seek the Republican nomination
in 2016 now maybe they were right if
justice eisenhower had done don't forget
oh when he was president of Columbia in
1952 that effort of course failed when
Petraeus is affair with Lilly
with the Paula Broadwell became public
and the Obama administration really cut
off his head the surge interact helped
it wasn't the decisive factor there and
any other number of factors that were
more important the Anbar awakening in
which the Sunni leadership decided they
wanted no part of the ISIS leadership of
the decision of Shiite cleric Elsa Saud
ray to disband his Mahdi army which Iran
told him to do but in any event by the
end of 2007 a semblance of order had
been achieved and in late 2008 just
before he left office Bush went to
Baghdad to sign an agreement providing
for the withdrawal of American forces
from Iraq by the end of 2011 that was
you recall when they disgruntled Iraqi
took off his shoes and three of them on
push
let me suggest that Bush's decision to
invade Iraq was the worst foreign policy
decision ever made by an American
president and if anyone can think of
anything it's worth please please let me
know that doesn't necessarily mean that
Bush was America's worth President
Herbert Hoover probably has a lot Bush's
domestic Bush did well as domestically
as president No Child Left Behind has
been a valuable contribution to the
educational program particularly for
children from disadvantaged families the
amendment of Medicare to provide
prescription drugs for seniors his
remarkable achievement Bush also took
the lead in the global fight against
AIDS particularly in Africa and under
his leadership the disease has some
degree been brought under control
Bush remains active in the fight he also
expanded American free trade when Bush
took office the United States had
free-trade agreements with Israel Canada
and Mexico it now has free trade
agreements with 16 countries which also
included an agreement with Putin and his
early term to reduce a nuclear arsenal
that each country maintained and really
he improved relations with China
I think Bush is most important
achievement however was to contain the
economic meltdown in 2008 against all of
his instincts and deeply held beliefs he
bailed out Wall Street and the American
auto industry and avoided another Great
Depression
unlike the war in Iraq or the fight
against terrorists at home this time
Bush listened to his advisers Hank
Paulson who was Secretary of the
Treasury and Ben Bernanke at the Federal
Reserve carved out a strategy of support
and Bush adopted
from bailing out subprime mortgage
lenders and insurance conglomerates to
rescuing the market itself with a
massive troubled asset relief program
tarp Bush deserves credit for taking the
necessary action he's a remarkable
achievement and probably saved the
world's economy and when they failed to
rescue Lehman Brothers that was Paulson
more than bush
I really haven't said anything about
Bush's personal life let me be very
brief he was always an early riser he
got up at 5:45 in the morning still does
goes to bed shortly before 10:00
physical fitness buff exercised for two
hours a day in the White House gym but
it wasn't a detail man he wanted short
descriptions brief memos he and Laura
were close the White House kept
entertaining to a minimum I haven't said
anything about Laura she was a major
source of support for the president
she took her responsibilities seriously
and did not seek the limelight she
usually accompanied Bush on his trips
abroad and provided great comfort for
him Paul sarbanes a long-serving United
States Senator from Maryland
as you know and a staunch Democrat told
me he thought Laura was the best first
lady he had ever met and Paul became a
member of Congress when Pat Nixon was
first lady
as ex-president Bush has been exemplary
unlike most of his predecessors he
doesn't miss the office doesn't try to
second-guess Obama curious if you can't
believe this but after the after the
election after Obama was sworn in Bush
told friends and in Dallas free at last
in many respects he's a model for what
ex-president should be as I said I don't
think George Bush is America's worth
president but I do believe that his
decision to attack Iraq as the worst
foreign policy decision ever made by an
American president and it gets worse as
time goes on thanks very much
[Applause]
please yes sir thank you very much for
your time I think your presentation and
book is quite time timely with the
Chilcott inquiry report in the UK today
the question I have is that you seem to
present a individual who may be
unqualified to assume the position of
president and yet and I note I noticed
two two kind of pivotal historical
points that might have changed the
course of history
the first was how george w bush was
selected as republican nominee in the
primaries over john mccain and if things
were different otherwise you know that
would have significantly changed the
course of history and secondly Al Gore's
brush-off of Bill Clinton in the
Democratic race as well so I guess the
question I have is you know as a
historian looking back what lessons and
your in your work do you find that we
can learn as far as picking qualified
leaders in the 2016 I'm not sure I I
don't think that that's a question that
I can easily answer and and I think I'll
just let sit at that if you don't mind
yeah I just have one question
Morris Berman in one of his books
mentioned george w bush's drinking and
mentioned that he stopped drinking but
he didn't take the steps necessary to
grow up and I seriously I mean I I look
around and I think untreated alcoholics
can sometimes be very dangerous because
they're running around unimpaired and
still thinking and you know racking on
impulse and doing all sorts of stuff
like the thing you mentioned on the
Abraham Lincoln sort of like getting up
in front of the mic and go oh I know
it's neat let's do this and
going on from there but I was just
asking if you have any reflections on
something no that's that's very
interesting in it and I didn't know that
but but I I think you're absolutely
right
professor Smith I'm a college student
here in the Washington DC area
and several years ago I read Europe and
a few years ago I read your biography of
president dies um are you able to hear
me no I'm as certain several years ago I
read your biography of President
Eisenhower which is one of the most
interesting and meaningful books which
is one of the most interesting and
meaningful books that I've read um my
question is as follows um what I'm I
know for example that you serve
I read for example that you served in
Berlin during in the US military would
you say that you had any life
experiences which were particularly
helpful for you in the context of
writing biography and if you did have
any such experience about were they and
how were they particularly helpful you
mean my military my my military
experience or others or any experience a
about my service in Berlin I live next
door to norm Swartz call from the BOQ
for two years but it really goes back to
my childhood here in Washington DC my
grandmother lived with us when before I
started school my grandmother always
read biographies to me so I've always
been interested in biographies and when
I was a graduate student at Columbia
before I took my orals of the chairman
of the department wanted me to bring
bring him a list of all the books I had
read which I did and he said gee there
are a lot of biographies here yes I
thought I followed it for years thank
you
just to pick up a little bit on the last
question how do you see Bush in the
light of Eisenhower's legacy how how
would I sonow or have assessed Bush's
record and in the light of what's been
going on in the Republican Party how do
you see eisenhower dealing dealing with
that on the first question don't forget
Eisenhower was elected by his promise to
win the war in Korea and he went to
Korea and saw it was unwinnable and he
came back and immediately made peace and
and the United States needed peace for
the for the remaining eight years of
Eisenhower's term so that's an hour
having seen war firsthand didn't want to
get back into one how would I soured
season they don't don't forget when
Eisenhower won the nomination against
Taft in 1952 eyes now represented the
liberal wing of the Democratic of the
Republican Party and for the next eight
years maybe longer than that it was a
liberal wing of the Republican Party
that dominated Taft was the candidate of
the conservative wing of the party and
and he lost and I said I really hadn't
had no use for them I don't think it's
generally well known but it was
Eisenhower behind the scenes who
conducted the operation against Joe
McCarthy was Eisenhower who could David
Welsh to be the
it to be the council and those in those
hearings so thank you
rather than restoring the civil that
relieved civil liberties that were lost
under Bush why do you think it is that
Democrats and other politicians that
have followed in his footsteps have
continued in the suppression of similar
Tories in it brought our country to the
point where people like Jimmy Carter
call it an older girl oligarchy III I
don't know it they were pub they were
the Republican Party leadership in the
Republican Party generally has moved
much further to the right than it was 40
or 50 years ago and and I think that
this this this view comes naturally I
I'm not sure of that but but but but I
think that's possible well the Democrats
have acted more like Republicans and
except for social issues also in the
money in politics issue as well is
another well you can say the whole
spectrum is Jake let's move to the right
thank you
I've read your biography of FDR I
thought it was absolutely first-rate and
I would like to say that we Americans
are fortunate that a Canadian scholar
will tackle so many of the questions in
American history I look forward to
reading the book I have to confess when
the University of Toronto hired me in
1965 for the in the department of
political economy is a very large
department 100 and some faculty members
I was the first American on board and
and and I was I went there they want to
be there because I wanted to teach
American government so so and in my
entire exposure at the University of
Toronto I taught American government but
but I see your statement that this was
the worst foreign policy decision ever
made I can't believe anyone here would
not concur with that it has unleashed
that sunni-shia war finally invited Iran
into the scene and my question is do you
think it's fair to they'll argue that we
can really blame the Iraq war largely
for the arrival of Isis absolutely
but because Saddam so long as he
remained in power kept a lid on on on
Iraq was a secular state at that time
and and he needed if you want to say it
his his military to keep the lid on and
I I so I think that I think that's
absolutely correct
I might say I've been thinking a great
deal about is is there another foreign
policy decision that you can work that
one might outrank Bush's decision to go
to war in Iraq and the only one that I
could possibly come up with was Harry
Truman's decision to drop the atomic
weapon on Hiroshima and Nagasaki
that's that's the only thing I can think
of the LBJ's decision on Vietnam I don't
put it at the same level but the point
you made earlier in in Vietnam there's
no carryover there's no Isis that
there's no guerrilla war there's no war
of terrorism and so forth they came out
of the Vietnam War as there is here yes
I think that's the principal distinction
between the two thank you another
question about Colin Powell I just I
just wanted to ask you know what's your
thoughts about Colin Powell to be seems
like a tragic hero that he may have a
lot of remorse and yet his story really
has that no one's ever shone the light
on his story and would you consider
there's a very good biography of : pal
written by the reporter for the
Washington Post and that was a tragic
figure he Bush wanted him he was Bush's
first cabinet appointee which was really
one of him but but he was he was quickly
shut out by the White House and he was
really in the wilderness for four years
he gained the answer that this may be in
your book when find out when we get to
reading it how directly involved was
Bush in the disastrous decisions to
disband the army in the bath party
Jerry Bremer gets blamed for some of
that that was Bush did Bush give the
order
no but should not give the order but but
but Bremer gave the order
it was brimmer's decision but but Bremer
was instructed to go over and and bring
democracy to Iraq and and when Bush when
Bremer did make the order Bush
immediately approved it there was no
tension but but Bush is not ordering
so well I'm short so we've had a few
late glancing mentions of the current
nominee for president in the Republican
Party and I've noticed and this is a
bipartisan thing among Democrats and
Republicans there tends to be a great
deal of sympathy or renewed positive
feelings towards george w bush
presidency in wake of the current
nominee what do you think of that really
yes my dad for instance is an old school
Democrat and thinks that among his group
of people he feels like I'll draw a
parallel as an example Trump's views on
barring Muslims from entering our
country versus perhaps george w bush's
repeated mentions that islam is a
culture of peace things like that
well III I'm sure I'm surprised that the
belief that that Bush's reputation is
improving I think if you look at it
today at the report of the of the
English investigation of bush and Blair
it's not it's not going to improve i but
buck done Simon in Chester when it
wanted me to write an op-ed on comparing
Bush and Trump and I said no
laughs I'd ask the same thank you for
speaking I was also intrigued by what
let me to come here is your uh when I
read into Ruby said going to her he
wasn't the worst president but going to
Iraq was the worst hmm foreign policy
and I got in like to ask well what was
else was in that top five but he kind of
touched on that with someone else's
question sort of flipped that question
what what are some of the best foreign
policy decisions or the best if you've
thought of that the best foreign policy
well I think you have to go back to the
Roosevelt administration and and
certainly Eisenhower decision to make
peace in Korea it wasn't what was a
breakthrough Eisenhower was work
Eisenhower was working very closely with
with with Khrushchev at the time to
improve relations and then he screwed it
up when he sent Francis Gary Powers over
on the u2 but with the Paris summit
would have would have shortened the Cold
War by a great deal by a great deal you
go back to the Eisenhower that the the
Bush administration administration I
think he probably have to go back there
but but maybe certainly President
Lincoln decision to maintain the Union
you you have to admit
thank you
well I think you have a consensus that
the Iraq war will under George Bush was
the worst foreign policy decision but
how do you treat his the war against
Afghanistan which I think was weakened
by Iraq but also has is still going on -
well and against Afghanistan you're
quite right it was weakened by Bush's
decision to go into Iraq but I'm going
to take a minority position on this I'm
sure but I'm not sure that the war in
Afghanistan was necessary look you've
got the accidents that happened on 9/11
four planes were hijacked three of them
crashed in the buildings that's not a
reason to go to war you handle that as a
legal issue or you try it in the courts
if you find anyone else who was involved
but you don't go to war for something
like that now that may be in a minority
position on that but that's what I
believe no I think that bush welcomed
the possibility to be a war hero like
his father I'm not sure he welcomed it
uh
but I'm sure he responded to it thank
you thank you so we have a couple
the Richard Clarke has suggested that
perhaps George Bush should be tried as a
war criminal you have any comments on
that
yes III III don't think presidents are
guilty of war crimes I mean III think
that period Bush a lot of credit for
handling the financial crisis there was
an HBO movie about it and it sort of
portrayed Paulson and Bernanke and
Geithner as making policy and then at
the last minute said maybe we should
consult the White House in this before
we release it well I don't think they I
think they did make policy but I don't
think they said at the last minute let's
consult the White House I think they
knew they had to consult the White House
and I think they did an extremely good
job of bringing Bush along which was
contrary to all of Bush's views and but
but he he I also think that Bush
realized he had stubbed his toe earlier
and he had he had messed up the Iraq
thing and and I think he was much more
inclined to listen to Paulson and
Bernanke professor Smith would you like
to discuss the renewal of the Saudi
Arabia oil concessions during this time
of both Bush Wars
I'm not sure I'm qualified to do that
but I think but I raise a question I
think it's certainly a very important
consideration but but but I I don't know
the details of is sufficiently to begin
to give you
[Applause]